know how reject nation great Galahad
jonald we're gonna watch the gameplay
trailer or whatever an trailer is 40
[ __ ] eight minutes we're gonna watch
an hour of someone playing a video game
just like you love to do when going over
to visit your friends and your kid
reaction videos we do full leg TV show
reactions over at our patreon what do
you know covering shows like
supernatural attack on Todd and
Fullmetal Alchemist brother there's a
quite a few shows actually go check this
out over there patron the daesh I want
to give it today to a fairly new patron
he goes by anti everything on our
patreon but you know what's funny of
that anti everything he is one
supportive mofo his name is actually
abri looking up his name fascinating
fascinating name what it essentially
means is fair ruler of the little people
you've got to take care of the little
people Aubry you got to take care of the
little people if you have the power to
control little people oh man you can
make some awesome sketches which version
of you mean like actual little people or
just you know the little guy in life
because either one works you know after
was a baby
okay I'm not using the offensive term no
you're not but they're funny they they
can be I'm sure everyone's got a sense
of humor they're funny control them
oh boy inappropriate we got a lot of get
here
don't open debt inside oh ouch Jackie
this guy's body cyber welcome to the
gameplay demo walkthrough of CD Projekt
RED upcoming title cyberpunk 2077 okay I
heard of driven eight open-world RPG set
in a dark version of the future before
we start a small but important
disclaimer the game plays out to see is
from a work-in-progress version of the
game everything you see is potentially
subject we're showing you 48 minutes of
a work in progress cyberpunk 2077 and
they're going to play a piece really
huge tests know for the very small penis
this is an archive I look very real
before appearance we need to define our
backstory what you choose here will
unlock different possibilities later in
the game that's pretty cool also you can
use an array of different options to
modify how you look see looks like that
body time what's ours mate that's shapes
makeup skin tone and many many but
visualizer should start watching yeah
you'll notice destroy yourself cyberpunk
2077 features a fluid classist
and you'll be able to model your last
throughout the game never a list place
near the beginning of the game already
invited Jackie along with a net runner
named team are hired to find and
Pinker's a girl whose locator implant
locator implant went dark we're in the
free state of Northern California he
point when t77
is a first-person role-playing game nice
perspective enables us to maximize your
emerge that's a specific manner taxed
the way I know
it's like that seen an upgrade yes I was
thinking of it it looks like these stats
were kidnapped two people to harvest
their implants nice okay
seen several feature movies like that
yeah a couple ideas like that things are
about to get you oh that's cool that
temporarily allows us to use the karez
nikana me the what the president coffee
bill yes any definitions to flash on
screen all those points or voice is
caress Nicole okay very good very good
okay slow-mo you just shot the ball
[Music]
that's cheating wow it's like tread so
you got a really a yeah huh
which is a cyberpunk like movie pension
but cover how now go back in little pal
and see how like you got a little like
bullet show yeah why can't you play
naked
I'm sure if you beat the game enough
time babe you can start off naked yeah
in the menu building yourself
like the sky like are they gonna find
her taking a [ __ ] I like when people
call people [ __ ] for dying whoa wow
that's a giant bathtub damn whoa those
are nipples yeah this is look good
no in a minute jacking in a biome on
[Music]
oh it is pretty good this would be
cooling VR flattened do I look good or
blinking and stuff got the shower
removing it wish I could hoist that guy
when you cosplay cost the bookie
kalbarri so they're not gonna take that
[ __ ]
[Music]
whoa Keri Russell that might read her
Pulp Fiction uma Thurman stabbed in the
chest it turns out a virus disrupted the
girls locator implant we fixed that and
now help is in bounds really hard not to
look at that nipple at the bottom of the
street I know graphically it's just in
the flavor just check out her whole body
the whole time and not pay attention to
where we're walking I'm sure yeah many
many people will find a way whether you
guys don't have a very good bet I'm an
editor yeah what that what gam Dix
why does everyone a dick in the future
control
secured diam I can use those medications
yeah man right into your right in your
brain why are those guys [ __ ] oh no
man like everybody's more of an [ __ ]
in the future Oh clear that was trauma
team below a kind of high-end premium
medical insurance yes we've delivered
the tari and teba has notified us that
the scavengers have called in
reinforcements let's get out of here
before they arrive wait a minute what's
the real fight it's how we're good guys
how much I mean you know we're we're
ambiguous expendabulls in some way feel
like if we're killing a lot of people
were probably ambiguous
we just saved someone there's so much
nudity in this game
oh we together
North California huh the free state of
is a mature visceral experience and as
such it will let you explore a variety
of different interactions with the game
world and as you just saw its people
damn these people are all hot I know in
the future make it all the time the job
with their chests Envy obviously has
some money to burn brain health calling
[Music]
that guy's okay that's kind of prefer
just say it that way and we have an
appointment with our before we leave
let's take a good look around our name
night see the song on the radio is dead
soccer boy Johnny silver it's part of
our creative process to draw inspiration
from the pen and paper system created by
Mike Pond Smith and to put our own 2077
spin okay Wow so much details okay it's
like a like to take these trusty pistol
this gun room is soundproof
better be yeah what I hear people just
firing off the bedroom pills yeah I also
do a point-blank target practicin see
cyberpunk 2077 the jacket not only
provides us with protective stats like
armor but it also increases our street
street cred as I have experienced the
player of wires by completing side
missions it is used to unlock new
vendors and content throughout night
scene so this jackets better project
let's go meet Jack B's current apartment
is Loki dirt and girl a mega build a
huge building complex that forms a micro
Society of its own in this timeline
technology in the world have evolved in
some ways that seem familiar but
entirely surprising you know
as an exam I upon that suite you mean
this system what's gonna happen tomorrow
we make sure I read every detail in the
world's law so everything has its
purpose and slates believable bucka
bucka slice how much of a slice a big
part of our RPG experience is having a
world that is interactive here a generic
ad has morphed into an advertisement
specifically tailored informing her of
the nearest venues she can purchase the
product oh that's neat in this case yeah
it shows us where to find some Nyko
lesotho
oh damn like a training robot boxing a
robot we're gonna terrify her
getting a drink does nothing for the
game overall but it is cool details oh
good the good tickets to the gun show
this is Wilson one of knight city's many
guns why I'll be checking his wares but
you can purchase an upgrade your weapons
and gear throughout this is it looks
like Ron Jeremy I'm pretty sure they
baseball fingers are located on the
coast of the free state of North
Carolina is a tale of violence and
oppression array looks like their
opponent we are working hard to make
whoa no loading screen currently that
wants no loading former industrial this
room where crime now mixes with money
this game's gonna be a hit gonna be a
[ __ ] hit man
Wow very impressive look I got shorts
this does look like oh this makes you
want to Explorer you live at City while
it doesn't lie Universal CityWalk yeah
former greatly enhanced crowd and
community systems to create the most
believable city in any open-world game
you just kill them streets the facets of
life although you probably can do to
your gameplay ooh
we need these cross walks in this world
we have to wait to cross the street
that's how I always used to play grand
theft auto's like I would try to follow
the rules of the road just to make the
game a little harder slacker okay
slacker McFly that's Rikuo doing
[Music]
exposition you see that caddy need to
walk going over there and get us a job
aina haina it's a term of endearment I
think
only to be a zero rippers it turns out
we've caught the attention of one of
night city's biggest players Dexter
DeSean a fixer a person who gets things
done he wants to discuss the job very
generic description a fixer a guy who
gets them done a criminal different
error that's good
I got the details here and watch this
[ __ ] on TV sure yeah no let me out
just textures
[Music]
what can I do to prove that my nature
business shooter
oh no that's risk see you got a classic
tale psycho good just doing this thing
jump the Corcoran woman got away
now I need me that little town guy they
call it the flat
of course I got the eddies to buy it but
me and the Maelstrom boys ain't best
friends no flow to our convo
okay corporation she's under hood for
the dogs he was a big ho you could use
yeah he repeat most that robot are so
see you at the afterlife soon as the job
oh yeah I wish we can make money for
real
it seems Dexter has given us a test of
sorts to see if we're worried he wants
us to retrieve a piece of high-tech
combat yeah a local game dirty girl
[Music]
god I hope this narrator playing the
game right eeeh they summed up exactly
what this is the guys Tom's diner
dude dude I've been there bad corporate
skills man
first exit off skyline going towards the
NID it's George channel under the
overpass meet you there
the situation is tricky because the
contract giver is a corporate agent who
seems a little high-strung yeah before
we get down to business
it's a great idea visit our River though
River dock that sounds cool dude this
bucket slice place is a blowing up
classic franchise when are we gonna get
one near us dirt girl
how many dirt girls oh man it's gonna be
a problem for me i delay the mission so
much just to interact with all these all
these things that keeps popping up on my
screen I'm interested crime is a common
occurrence
tonight city is not a safe place life
that over is not easy
is that like a reproduction of a crime
scene yeah I think so
that's cool she'd be a cop that'd be how
much sure is this game here first up I
got charm again love the most
unnecessary dialogue choices doctor
vector we're at a river doc clinic
ripper doctor specialist vendors who
offer people the possibility to install
or upgrade their cyber
okay are you supposed to figure this all
out I rewrote your plating yep just drop
you in yeah right up to make [ __ ] just
got real in the major leagues
Dexter Shawn yes Brian I'll bring you
the antes later with interest you know
what he's gonna betray air time I swear
no Syd didn't hi bro hope that future
[ __ ] oh I want to be able to play that
part
whoa that's Karoshi
that's night guy and she'd be about
right under the circumstances
these graphics are god-awful yeah so
fake look at gosh you think they'd be
better if I really hope this is just a
work in progress an optical scanner like
I said just please data on your cornea
and a subdermal wedding ribbon likes not
labeled whoa it's not entirely sure
where the hell I got it
still they they don't talk to koroshite
a damn I'm ready
carve away okay now for the fun stuff
they made you lead on yours right here
but all the guys in the future sounds
like Perkins
yeah with gravelly voice don't worry
Bryan Cranston's gonna play this gun
the way by play makes you sound like a
dentist you're always going on remember
I'm old I got a shake again I can't
could slip it I don't like you I could
[ __ ] this up you might feel a little
discomfort glitches now you get to live
as this eyeball sir every woods human
just with some just with a lot of techno
upgrades yeah doesn't worth to you I
gotta get crackin you can zoom in on
things and take a closer look the ants
enhance this is fantastic addition we
can analyze objects get details on enemy
weak points or gang affiliation
scanners would eventually sink if your
thought processes will read your
intentions
read your intent like a chill Wow
you should see your hope in the brand or
the subdermal weapon grip links to our
skin and shows us weapon information
like ammo count and fireman's they're
really subdermal is the base damage on
all connected weapons not that I don't
know what to say
give her an option I say thank you
remember the dosage two whips now and
another due in an hour
thanks no no what's this tip yeah we
trust this get you what you can do it's
whatever
it's talking to us
River doc
while some reproduce
legal others provide black-market
services for the right price they can
even offer to install illegal
military-grade cyberware
we're not gonna be doing any of that no
no we're trying to keep this try as much
as legal parameters as possible legalist
criminals the way you should play video
games let's go it on boot does every
time it's easy to use them fancy as
optics to scan by no use
why don't I freeze things in a way for
you to actually check out these two
upgrades for the video game you play
[Music]
scared him
we got fancy-ass card you're parked like
a douchebag he's good look at your card
guy looks an awful lot like one of those
scavengers we took out earlier if you
weren't there to say that I wouldn't yes
what is the algorithm
it's a cool cars crisis super-powered
sports car running on YouTube go as fast
as you can come on if you ha and stop
you can't get pulled over now explore
night city of breathe in many different
colors on bikes and in other types of
people I'd like to see it in this
dimension so can I just spend all of my
time exploring looks like it oh cool oh
[Music]
man is I got a game right here yeah
oh I got one ready I think that was
intense sure that flying cow ad never
snows danger lurks around every corner
heed the day it does is ironic name half
the time what happens if you hit that
guy yourself
they are some pretty messed up pendejo
many forces are fighting he set alight
late but the mega corporations are the
real show
the agent we're going to meet represents
militant one of the largest companies in
the private military set well what do
they make poor pose let me guess
everyone's really good at guessing at
this game since cyberpunk 2077 is an RPG
preparation will be key when dealing
with knight city's powerful especially
when these are core bones instead of
just rushing in let's assess the
situation with our freshly installed
Karoshi optical skin there it's
difficult composite armor
yeah gotta do this don't move a damn
muscle not unless I start that is
the physics look amazing - is just like
the light knowing light hits everything
yeah these get other levels higher than
we are let's try to approach them
carefully by jumping down I jump up like
[ __ ] spider-man yeah whoa oh jeez Oh
you're insane I'll know in two seconds
flat [ __ ] thing ready all set
everyone seems so unreasonably and have
subjected us to a kind of lie detector
program the dialogue system in cyberpunk
23 the gun yeah grab the gun please
cowboy we're watching a dab game
delicious crab the cut maybe because you
said just little old me like that it
might be tempting to reach for the gun
but the consequence is time remember
these guys are really [ __ ] check this
guy thought about what I'd be thinking
the way people swear in this games is
this is natural of you [ __ ] I will I
will
oh you are stretching this better be
[ __ ] good gang goons who ripped you
off I never find out they got a bot I
want give me the funds to buy that buy
you can do it you want with the gang I
don't give a [ __ ] about the fees I want
my mole
well this audition is not going very
well
oh yes chips gotta make it into the
thieves terminal that's all I need
think you can do that and we got a deal
[Music]
fine amen
try to [ __ ] me in anything try to have a
always emphasized swear swear words in
this occasion said this dress it's kind
of goody dead the agent gave us the
money to buy the button give edge by
choosing to call the militant early we
have now opened up a non-violent path
through this quest of course we could
try and keep the month but that would
mean we'd have to take the merchandise
by force which requires a lot of
firepower I want to make this game as
non violence of an experience as
possible the goal is to get through
without killing anyone
went down about like I expected made a
deal and we're good to meet with
Maelstrom now did you know
sure is an option to feel bad when you
kill someone haha feel guilty
moment of silence simplest
[Music]
this is real RPG there be consciousness
yeah SUV we can choose the violence West
do we go in guns blaze or do we try to
negotiate a give the narrator enough
time to talk no I cut them off you're
calling this for this demo let's try the
more diplomatic approach yeah that's
what we want to see handling things
Kylie hey they're being smart because
they know that everybody who's watching
this just wants to shoot everything up
and that's their motivation to buy the
game yeah all right want to talk to
voice which attitude just open the [ __ ]
up you say to me [ __ ]
turret mounts traffic militant care
psycho porch drummed out with
military-grade hardware worth millions
the guys were about to meet our
dangerous
oh they're members of the mail storm and
their obsession with body modification
way beyond even this world standards to
becoming machines they don't shy away
from even the most extreme measures
anti-personnel mine shredder
it looks like they made this abandon all
foods meat factories they're high up
charming seriously
more stairs maybe we should have taken
him by surprise
y'all April it was like that not us in
their sights though just keep moving
just keeps waving yeah
there's got to be a movie theater in
this game just to check out for a little
while Lucas I believe in the game they
invented the 20 new movies you can go
watch future classics this is a pretty
well guarded place you can imagine what
would have happened if we'd taken the
violent path
we'd be watching more entertaining
footage it might be a slightly different
kind of game but no this is really cool
though yeah that's cool look into Bible
model and TOD 12 looks like a spider
what what what are those faces do
exactly I don't know they're just all
Robo towel it's kind of cool I can
probably sense with body modifications
that's really cool yeah
I'll stand you can't move on your culo
makes you an easy target turn that
really necessary only see that up grace
sit your ass down or I played a bullet
you stop sit down you're single
alright [ __ ] it Bravo
come on lighten up
Oh
you can't just inhale everything better
just became legal it's totally crazy
there's my favorite part of the world so
far yeah people obsessive body
modifications like I said Stevie honest
double standard for
whoa action with pimping titanium fiber
and it could go anywhere
watch it will be adequately - this is
what the spider starts crawling up the
walls babe you look through ceilings you
could lose your much
what do you think how fascinating gotta
here
questions what the [ __ ] going on and
who the [ __ ] is this whoa
got 50 large in this crunch
you positively reek of military Wow look
at that that is scary
Wow Dexter DeSean threats please how
much you say you add UK pretzels
whoa moving dads this is the best part
of the whole whole gameplay yeah well
grab the spider dude all is poor people
died for nothing
poor Bob turns out the poor boys their
leader is making a break before we
figure out a way to leave let's grab the
splinter that controls the money from
one of these dead males from exactly
get that body moving what are your
houses why did he say that because it's
part of his character swears long
Spanish got us wherever we go
what else do we have nice whoa tech shot
tech weapons for your rounds that
penetrate walls and other types of stuff
they also have an alternate fire that
allows you to power up shots and deal
more damage why do I get the impression
this narrator wasn't watching the
footage when she probably can you
actually liked hack stud luckily our
engineering skills should allow us
assemble that maintenance man so we can
get through the door yeah
there are many skills in the game that
players can apply in solving problems
the engineering skill can be used to fix
disassemble and disarm devices so this
point we're going to unlock the
abilities of a high-end character to
showcase some of the different mechanics
are [ __ ] there's a cool good buy wow you
know we're walking away from that one of
the new weapon modules we now have
installed is a ricochet targeting system
connected to our eyes this allows
players lets off wall that that is very
unique make it like a fun game I don't
know what get out of game ever seen that
that's that's cool they said another
targeting system that will reveal
enemies behind walls paired with the
penetrating rounds of our tech shot it's
a dead whoa oh that dudes legs off looks
like we found some loot
this is a smart it's one of the more
advanced weapon connects to your wife I
will look at the track voice Amanda it's
one of many different weapons players
can acquire weapons are building modules
that allow for deep customization smart
guns smoke these fall short
what are those strips
boom oh yeah what is that thing called
charisma Carson
jealous Oscar shallow Cheska
[Music]
[Music]
just a reminder everything you've seen
and are about to see including this
particular feature about to show you is
from a work-in-progress version of the
movie and they change over the course
try some [ __ ] amazing neural some how
in the world of cyber once you are
jacked into a network you have access to
everything it connects through this
Maelstrom gangman we've now connected to
the gang hideouts internal network this
is the building's personnel system let's
focus on the squad Oh Strom ganger we
just connected from here we can deploy
software that effects the whole squad
for now we'll simply unlock the ability
to potatoes
there's too many options using the back
door we unlocked the minute we'll
install a virus that jams the connection
between the Maelstrom ganger and is
whether this will prevent him from
firing
Wow yeah you can also double jump and
bounce off of walls which makes us a
very agile fast solo little ramp up down
noises basically you're impossible to
kid yeah
if you die you must suck at this guy
because your options are limitless of
what you can do they're all cool
yeah it's surprisingly dark in this room
so sweet we just found a corporate a
trifle for the weapons our table hula he
did not nothing area no we were gonna
find that Corbeau now he didn't music
like us of sweets nobody wrote this in
this our weapons are not dealing
because he's packing you're not good
make yourself no yep she recorded
earlier original the week brawl I talked
about not running into during the shield
a weak spot just keep shooting to hit
people shooting
Oh
Wow cool whoa oh there it is that's it
I like that in games when you have to
shoot the back of them yeah right
shields down
sure damage to shoot room now good
okay let's put him down and get this job
over ah there you go eight go
that wasn't the smoothest raid but we've
got the bots and Dex should be happy and
his heads blowed off what would have
happened if we hadn't met with the
vanilla Tech agent or told Royce about
the agent and her plans or just decided
to buy the bot our selves so many
options so many possibilities and each
will have consequences that will ripple
through the game world and your storm
swings that's just one quest and finish
the job
it will take you six months to make this
video you'll never have to stop playing
cyberpunk 2 comes out you'll be totally
lost because you'll never have beaten
the game
really ought to work together more often
your chip had the clap that is not
discreet
I [ __ ] you over you [ __ ] the gang over
somewhere at the start of the story
somebody [ __ ] the Corp see how this
works now only the court gets what it
wants air by [ __ ]
somebody else
the Raging [ __ ] to ever see my dad do
don't worry I think Jackson's went down
the table of the afterlife hey mister
Dex well you were right - got a good
feeling yeah I like this game it's good
that we're partnering up with this
particular criminal just became Knights
City
yeah finally scientists the door open
not the only thing I want to pry open
right now is a bottle of scotch this is
the longest act one I've ever seen in my
entire life
all right it's just a 48 minutes setup
okay but our story is just
[Music]
this concludes our gameplay demo thanks
Rob ah well man gotta say it certainly
lived up to the trailer that we saw that
came out of e3 it was different than I
expected it to be I think what actually
really caught me off guard for a while
when I was watching it and it took me a
second to note it I wasn't expecting it
to be first-person point of view that's
actually been a big deal about this game
because Witcher 3 is third-person and
like everybody lost their mind over that
it's the same creators right yeah same
developer and so a lot of people have
actually been kind of displeased by the
first-person POV in this game I like it
yeah I do too I mean the bummer about it
because like when you look at especially
in the beginning when you're seeing like
the designs you could put together the
characters you can choose and the
backstory and all that when you're
seeing just a human design of their
naked body yeah you're like wow it looks
so in-depth and so detailed that I'm
expecting to play as their promote the
play as them as naked but that wouldn't
be opposing a guy or a girl
I do the entirely naked very much like
the whole strip changes over all your
dialogue is why are your clothes so are
you naked everywhere you go just affects
the entire explain why so I was excited
to see them in third-person the whole
time but when you're playing in
first-person I can imagine that actually
arguably makes for a more immersive
experience because of the fact that this
is an open world than in the night city
territory I like how it's called night
city and this whole gameplay took place
during the day which is a side note
ended in the evening I was like oh it's
evening now this is arguably the time I
wanted to see night city in is the
evening because if you're dealing with
criminal underworld we're talking about
how the city never sleeps with the crime
I want to see how how much evil more
politically evil even does it get during
during the nighttime because they hint
it out like some political debates that
are probably happening here have a
corporate girl in here there's some
political intrigue happening the big
appeal when you call cyberpunk I
immediately flash to movies that have
cyberpunk
in there because for me personally my
favorite moment in terms of just world
exploration was when they went to buy
the spider thingy yeah and those dudes
who are obsessed with like their bodies
yeah yeah they're gonna wake caved-in
face yeah no brains right yeah just
lights inside it's so jarring and
unsettling to look at even and yet to
have to like go in first person interact
with you have you got a big TV or if
there's some way to play this in a
headset yeah it's gotta be pretty
jarring
cuz I feel like when I usually watch
these gameplay bits it's usually a lot
of violence and mixed with exploration I
feel like the majority this was actually
exploration then some gun action here or
there
I gotta say I mean as much as we were
clowning on the tone of this video I do
appreciate when it's sort of like let's
not just get carried away shooting
everything let's kind of explore the
features let's take in the world because
also just like the open world looks
incredible amount of time will go to
just poking around in what stuff is
around now this game will take me
forever to be it's my problem with
open-world games like this where there's
a plot and an open-world to back it up I
just want to finish the plot yeah I just
want to finish the plot so I can feel
like I beat the game and then I can just
chill out in the world I never do
another vision the thing with the
scanning is people's names keep popping
up of what this option is it's more than
just like looking at a little map on the
screen and seeing the options you can go
to because that's easier to ignore but
if I'm like walking the streets and oh
yeah this this subtitle appears and what
this guy or girl is this person hears
what that is now this right at my face
what I wonder what the side quests are
gonna be like cuz I imagine in a game
like this you probably [ __ ] funny
over a lot of site quality of randomness
that you could actually deal with in
this game it looks like a lot of the
voice acting for me is is kind of a
mixed bag honestly it feels very video
game when I got back into gaming this
year early in the year it started with
the Last of Us which has amazing
voiceover work which sounds like they're
doing real scenes and here like
sometimes when they're talking I'm like
it sounds like you weren't in the room
with other people when you were
recording the dialogue you know I think
the only bit of forgiveness I will toss
the game's way for that particular thing
is like in a lot of older side
punk movies there is that kind of
dialogue yeah greener actors who are
like yeah come over here yeah yeah yeah
it's not without the aesthetic I could
have used a little more natural dialogue
for my sake but it felt you know
appropriate for a video game anyway if
it's the world definitely if it's the
world yeah who is that porn star that I
keep like sasha grey no man one-star
shaved head or undercut she have like a
she only have one shaved side or
something is this her
Christy Mack yeah looks like Christy
Mack doesn't she look like Christy Mack
oh thanks Google for making that pretty
quick damn no yeah they do look like
Christy she does look like Christy back
yes the girl I was thinking of the whole
time yeah maybe she was the body model
for this yeah they got to pick up the
designs from someplace bunch of horny
developers honestly that the part that
overwhelms me the action moment when you
have so many options of the kind of guns
you could use that's different a way to
like infect people with viruses hack
into someone and then she will let
through a whole scanning of the entire
complex and everything like be quick
enough to think of all these options
that come at hand here that's what gives
me a little tense and overwhelm is and I
gotta mess this up they give you
something appalling in the corner like
oh yeah I can do this yeah I plug into
everything these guys yeah just the
aesthetics of the world I mean like it
looks like a totally fun you know first
person's style shoot him up video game
but it looks like there's gonna be a
good amount of strategy and just tons
and tons of like that this makes me
excited for the action cuz it looks like
the action could potentially be perfect
yeah especially if he's talking about
that spider thing too it's like we
didn't really get to use it but later on
the game you know you never know if you
might get bigger tech like that and
other abilities that are outside of just
you shooting people yeah I'm excited for
the world building that's gonna be
taking place here because I imagine that
there's gonna be some you know
characters but sure is like a very
sinister greedy kind of world so it's
gonna happen to jack guys know it's
gonna be a lot of people betraying you
there's gonna be a lot of
double-crossing on
I think there's gonna be a lot of great
plot points in here as well I like games
that allow you to like choose what how
you want to respond to people get shape
the demeanor of the game and the
relationships that you have you know
where all your choices affect how the
game plays out cuz honestly I got I kind
of got some chills when the narrator was
like now imagine if we had made this
choice instead imagine if we admit this
choice and sake because I was looking
back and I was going wow how differently
would this have actually played out what
it it's more than just different choices
a dialogue but you still get the same
outcome I imagine that this can actually
lead to different outcomes there's
different types of endings and
alternative ways this can go down so
it's like there's no one way to do it so
this this has great repeat value for
playing as well all right when we get
the game we'll both twitch streaming you
on one side and the other and see how it
basically made the game that you will
never be able to actually complete
definitive no I need one game for the
rest of your life it's gonna be this
game somebody out there is gonna figure
out they're like I boiled it down to the
same choice every time I played it the
exact same experience I'll see in these
open-world games sometimes I don't
really you know waste time by exploring
you know just just living stuff somebody
rendered all those environment and well
yeah I mean there's that like when
they're talking about you know when you
wake up now let's look at the city
through the window to do is gonna be
prompting you yeah I mean do you have
she wakes up in bed with the other
player so my you go on dates in this
game there's nudity in here do you get a
have sex in this game Massacre all these
gangsters for coffee with that all the
all these things that you can do is just
living how far can you take the living
area cuz what I think of open-world a
lot of the time with with open-world
they tend to be period pieces that come
to mind something like Witcher you know
where you have a lot of environment to
go off of I think a futuristic
open-world is that arguably a little bit
more appealing for my specific taste
because I'm like oh this is down there
Oh California I California I'm
interested to see you know look like you
see based on something you're already
familiar with it yeah the possibilities
are endless
and you know with the way games have
progressed and all the physics yeah but
for real and the graphics are so much
more clear it's like now you can really
be shown something magical that you've
never seen before and that's why I said
like I don't know if this will make it
to a VR extension of any kind but like
the game like this really makes me
excited for something like that cuz to
be able to kind of put it on ya round at
a world like this would be so awesome
cuz it is like just a hypothesis of what
the future could look like alright guys
well this was really cool I really I
really enjoyed this I get why y'all went
nuts in the comments yeah alright guys
well thanks for watching you can
subscribe to the reject nation click
that notification Bell cuz of YouTube
[ __ ] ring the bell and check us on
patreon where we got full-length TV show
reactions for so many shoes that are
awesome and weekly Q&A is another goodie
yah-ha